according to the American Tribune Green
Party candidate and president not so
elect Jill Stein has been arrested for
embezzling funds from her election
recount money to throw a massive
marijuana themed party in California
which is Spanish for marijuana her
guestlist allegedly included some of the
quote richest liberals in Los Angeles
also known as the @midnight writers the
comedians what are some things you might
overhear at Jill Stein's putt party
never had someone buzz in for someone
else before Kristen Schaal I need to get
higher so that I can forget that at Oak
first dine is at Oak for Trump all right
which one is Jill Stein I like how rich
is stoned voice is the same as let's see
we just called rich poverty Jill Stein's
pot party even though they've both been
do I still need to buzz you have to I'm
gonna do an impression of rich Fulcher
please I hope Donald Trump gets in there
and then we can fashion a bong out of
his hair
[Applause]
he's gonna greet you I'm better than you
are
shut up all right so I have a confession
to make that news story was completely
fake you guys totally fake totally
made-up but people are still sharing it
like it's real this is part of a very
troubling trend of people being stupid
fake news is everywhere these days
Google's been clamping down on it one
recent report found that the top 20 fake
news stories were interacted with on
Facebook almost 9 million times in the
weeks before the election fake news is
popular because essentially just plays
into people's confirmation biases they
want to feel like their right doesn't
matter if the information is real or not
as long as they see it written in a font
hey a pot that seems official